[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياضه نبداها كالمعتاد بالعلوي
صحيفه امريكيه تكشف العلاقات مع السعوديه
وثيقه واداره بايدن لم تجري اي مراجعه او
تقييم له
وكاله رايترز تؤكدان سعودي وعماني يصلان
صنعاء لبحث فرص السلام
14 وزيرا برئاسه الشيخ احمد النواب
في الرابعه ايضا
رابع تقف على واقع وجهه مسار في مكه انجاز
93% من البنيه التحتيه للمشروع حتى الان
[موسيقى]
رياض تختم ثلاثه ايام من فعاليات الجرجعان
احياء لعاده رمضانيه تراثيه
نشرت صحيفه بوليتيكو الامريكيه تقريرا حول
علاقه اداره الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
بالسعوديه ومدار خلال السنوات الماضيه من
وعود باعاده تقييمها صحيفه اكدت بان اداره
بايدن لا تستطيع الانسحاب من علاقاتها مع
السعوديه وما يعزز هذا التوجه الزياره غير
المعلنه لمدير وكاله المخابرات المركزيه
الامريكيه
الى السعوديه هذا الاسبوع لاعاده تاكيد
العلاقات الاستخباراتيه الوثيقه بين
واشنطن والرياض حول خطوه مراجعه العلاقات
مع السعوديه التي اعلنها بايدن اكثر من
مره بيانات الصحيفه ان الاداره الامريكيه
لم تجري فعليا اي مراجعه رسميه احد مساعدي
الحزب الجمهوري في الكونغرس اكد ان
المراجعه المزعومه التي حدثت بعد قرار
اوبك بلس واعلنت عنها الاداره الامريكيه
جاءت لان واشنطن شعرت بالحرج من القرار
وفقا للبوريتكون
فعلا اعتقد اولا انه كان هناك
فطور او البعض طبعا يصفها بانها كانت ازمه
في العلاقات او عدم ثقه
قامت بين الولايات المتحده والسعوديه
وخاصه بعد التصريحات التي ادلى بها الرئيس
بايدن السعوديه ستكون دوله منبوده عندما
كان مرشحا للرئاسه
وطبعا برزت ايضا كما ذكرتم هذه التباينات
في المواقف والانزعاج الامريكي بعد قرار
اوبك بلس في السنه الماضيه بتخفيض الانتاج
وحتى في الاونه الاخيره ولكن في نفس الوقت
الذي
جرد عليك اعتقد انه كان هناك فعلا نوع من
اعاده التقييم
لسوى المراجعه للسياسه الامريكيه وكان
هناك تيار كان هناك اكثر من تيار طبعا
هناك تيار في الكونجرس يطالب بتبني مواقف
متش محاسبه السعوديه بمعاقبتها بعدم ارسال
الاسلحه وغير ذلك هناك دعم له من بعض
المسؤولين ولكن هناك تيار اخر يعتقد بان
الاداره الامريكيه
ضيعت الطابه الى حد ما او اسقطتها من
اسقطت الكره الدبلوماسيه في من يدها وانها
او انها اتبعت دبلوماسيه فاشله ولم تاخذ
مصالح ودول حلفائها في المنطقه والشركائها
بعين الاعتبار او لم تمنحهم الاهتمام
الكافي وانه يجب اعاده النظر في ذلك ولذلك
راينا انه على الرغم من عدم ارتياح واشنطن
لتخفيض الاسعار كان هناك نوع من القرار
الذي اتخذ بعدم تصعيد
مع السعوديه لان العلاقات بين البلدين هي
علاقات وثيقه لا تزال هناك مصالح مشتركه
كثيره بين السعوديه والولايات المتحده
ويجب ان تاخذها الولايات المتحده دعاني
وكان هناك فعلا عده مؤشرات ايجابيه في
الاونه الاخيره في العلاقات بين الجانبين
مثلا وافق موافقه الكونجرس بعد ان رفع احد
اعضاء مجلس الشيوخ الذي كان يرفض تعيين
السفير او يعلق
برايك بسبب قضايا تتعلق
والموافقه على ارسال السفير الى السعوديه
ايضا الصفقه صفقه شراء طائرات بوينج من
الولايات المتحده من شركه بوينج قبل
السعوديه
والزياره التي تفضلتم واشرتم في اليها
ايضا زياره
الرئيس او مدير وكاله الاستخبارات
وهو يعتبر ايضا كان كما تعلم دبلوماسيا
بارسا كان رقم اثنين في وزاره الخارجيه
قبل تعيينه في منصب مدير وكاله
الاستخبارات المركزيه وهذه اطهرت بان
الولايات المتحده والسعوديه لا تزال على
الرغم من بعض التبانات لا تزال لديهم
علاقات قويه وتاريخيه وثيقه ان كانت
اقتصاديه ان كانت تعليم مياه عسكريه امنيه
وغير ذلك ولذلك فان كان نوع من التفاهم
والتقبل ولكن حتى ولو لم يكن مرحبا به
للمتغيرات فيما يتعلق مثلا بالصفقه التي
التفاهم الذي تم بين السعوديه وايران
ببصاصه الصين وتعزيز العلاقه ايضا مع
روسيا وان ذلك جاء كما يعتقد البعض هنا
طبعا هناك تفسيران مختلفان بعض يعتقد بان
السعوديه لا تزال ترغب في الحفاظ على
علاقه وثيقه مع الولايات المتحده وتتخذ
خطوات لذلك ولكنها قلقه من بعض المواقف
الامريكيه في الماضي وسبب اخر يرى بان
السعوديه ايضا تتبنى توجها جديدا سياسه
خارجيه جديده تاخذ بعين الاعتبار
المتغيرات الدوليه والتعدديه القطبيه
وتنظر الى هذه المساله من وجهه نظر
مصلحتها ومصلحه شعبها وبالتالي فان هذه هي
ايضا من بين العوامل ولكن كما قلت هناك
تفسيرات مختلفه لهذه التطورات جيد يعني
الدكتور باختصار هل نتحدث عن تحسن تدريجي
في العلاقه بين الرياض واشنطن واقعيه
امريكيه في النظر الى مكانه وقوه القرار
اليوم في الرياض ام انه ضعف اليوم ضعف
امريكي واضح الولايات المتحده لم تعد
قادره على اتخاذ القرار في الخليج العربي
برايه اعتقد انها ربما قد تكون مزيج من كل
هذه العوامل بدون شك ان هناك تحسن
ونقل قبل حوالي اسبوع ونصف او اسبوعين
تقريبا
تصريح نسب لمسؤول بارز امريكي ولكن يذكر
يذكر اسمه وهو ان العلاقه الان هي في وضع
افضل مما كانت عليه بكثير من ما كانت عليه
في بين السعوديه والولايات المتحده وان
الولايات المتحده تتفهم بعض المواقف التي
تتفهمها او تبنتها العربيه السعوديه ولذلك
اعتقد ان هناك فعلا تحسن في العلاقات ولكن
ايضا الولايات المتحده منشغله لديها
الكثير على طاولته على المائده الامور يجب
عليها ان تتعامل معها وتعالجها وواجهت عده
صدمات ربما في الاونه الاخيره وهذه ايضا
لها علاقه هي تريد الحفاظ على علاقاتها
وعلى دورها وهي لا تزال تقول لانها هناك
عده تطورات ايضا اخرى دكتور علاقات وثيقه
مع شركائها التقليدي على سبيل المثال
اتفاق السعودي الايراني الكثير من
الامريكيين من خلال متابعتنا ربما لوسائل
الاعلام للتعليقات ايضا بعض المسؤولين
يعتبرون ذلك انتصار للصين هزيمه لسياسه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
انضمام السعوديه ايضا في صفه شريك حوار
لمنظمه شانغهاي
زياره ويليام بيرز مثلا مدير وكاله
المخابرات الامريكيه وما قيل بانه جاء
يعني يعبر في زيارته عن انزعاج امريكي من
التقارب بين الرياض والطيران من الوساطه
الصينيه وغيرها كل ذلك الى اي مدى يمكن ان
يؤثر في العلاقه اليوم بين واشنطن وبين
الرياض
اعتقد ان اولا بدون شك واشنطن كان انزعجت
كانت منزعجه من
الدور الذي لعبته الصين في البساطه
الايرانيه السعوديه ورات بذلك انه دور
جديد تلعبه الصين على الساحه الاقليميه
وهذا طبعا بالتاكيد كما نتوقعه ومزعج
لواشنطن ايضا هناك عدد من مثلا رغبه
السعوديه في الانضمام لمنظمات شان عائله
التعاون هذه ايضا مزعجه ولكن في نفس الوقت
ايضا بدات هناك الواقعيين داخل الاداره
الامريكيه يقول بانه على الرغم من ان كل
هذه
القرارات التي اخذتها السعوديه فان
السعوديه لا تزال هي دوله لها علاقات
وثيقه مع الولايات المتحده هذه العلاقات
قديمه جدا وهي لن تهتز او لن تتاثر كثيرا
بسبب هذه
الامريكيه النوويه دكتور ريدموند هل ياتي
في هذا السياق في هذا الاطار في هذا
التوقيت له فعلا وهذه نقطه مهمه جدا اعتقد
ان الولايات المتحده ايضا بارسالها هذه
الغواصه النوويه
وعاده ارسال الغواصه مثلا او معظم الاوقات
يتم بسريه عاليه هذه المره نشرت صوره وقد
كان هناك حديث عنها وتم ربطها في وسائل
وسائل الاعلام الامريكي بانها اشاره على
ان الولايات المتحده لا تزال باقيه في
المنطقه وهي رساله طمانه لترسلها الى
اصدقائها في منطقه الشرق الاوسط ولذلك
اعتقد ان هذه قد تكون ايضا من بين الرسائل
التي ترغب واشنطن في ارسالها ولكن ايضا
البعض يقول بان وهذه الجانب الواقعيه التي
بدات يعترف بها بعض المسؤولين الامريكيين
قبل عده سنوات كانت الولايات المتحده
المشتري الاول للنفط من السعوديه الان
اكبر ثاني الصيني المشتريات السعوديه هي
ثاني اكبر مشتريات نفطيه في العالم وتاتي
من السعوديه وهذه ايضا عامل اخر مهم
بالنسبه ان السعوديه ايضا تاخذ مصالحة عن
الاعتبار شكرا جزيلا لك غريب الاستاذ في
العلاقات الدوليه
نقلت وكاله رايترز عن اعلام يمني ان وفدا
سعوديا واخر من سلطنه عمان وصل الى
العاصمه اليمنيه صنعاء لبحث جهود خلال
السلام وبحسب رؤيه فان اللقاء ستشمل
المبعوثه الاممي وقاده الحوثيين لبحث
تمديد الهدنه والعمل على اجراءات لبناء
الثقه اختبار التوصل الى حل سياسي شامل في
اليمن
رابع مستمره فيها بعد قليل وكاله انباء
الطلبه الايرانيه تكشف عن توجه وفد ايراني
لزياره السعوديه هذا الاسبوع من اجل اعاده
فتح السفر
اهلا بكم من جديد على الصعيد الاتفاق
السعوديه الايراني زارا فريق فني سعودي
العاصمه الايرانيه طهران تمهيدا لفتح
السفارات والقنصليات العرض التالي يلخص
لنا الخطوات التي اعقبت اتفاق العاشر من
مارس التاريخي
العاشر من مارس الماضي خطوه وبيان تاريخي
من بكين بالاعلان عن توافق سعودي ايراني
على استئناف العلاقات بين البلدين بعد سبع
سنوات من القطيعه تلت هذا التاريخ اتصالات
متبادله بين وزير الخارجيه السعودي الامير
فيصل بن فرحان ونظيره الايراني امير حسين
عبد اللهيان تمهيدا لاول لقاء بينهما
والذي جرى قبل ثلاثه ايام في السادس من
ابريل الجاري العاصمه الصينيه بكين كانت
في الواجهه مجددا بعد استضافتها اللقاء
نتج عنه بيان مشترك شمل بحث استئناف
الرحلات الجويه وتسهيل منح التاشيرات
وكذلك بدء ترتيبات اعاده فتح السفارتين
والقنصليه يوم امس زار فريق فني سعودي
العاصمه الايرانيه طهران الفريق معني
بمناقشه اليات اعاده افتتاح الممثليات
السعوديه في ايران في خطوه اخرى نحو تنفيذ
بنود الاتفاق الثلاثي الذي وصف بالمفاجئ
والتاريخي
لقد كشفته وكاله انباء الطلبه الايرانيه
شبهه الرسميه عن زياره وفد فني ايراني الى
السعوديه في هذا الاسبوع لتجهيز لكامل
الترتيبات لاعاده فتح السفاره الايرانيه
في العاصمه السعوديه الرياض ياتي هذا بعد
عقد اجتماع بين وزيري الخارجيه السعودي
والايراني في بكين في اول لقاء رسمي من
نوعه منذ اكثر من سبع سنوات اتاتي
التطورات بعد اتفاق تم التوصل اليه ببساطه
صينيه لاستئناف العلاقات بين القوتين
الاقليميتين
في الكويت صدر مرسوم امري اليوم الاحد
بتشكيل الحكومه الجديده في البلاد برئاسه
الشيخ احمد النواف الاحمد الصباح رئيس
مجلس الوزراء وكان الشيخ احمد النواف عين
رئيسا لمجلس الوزراء بامر اميري الشهر
الماضي الحكومه الجديده تعد الثالثه التي
يراسها احمد النواف خلال ثمانيه اشهر فقط
ضمت الحكومه 14 وزيرا منهم سته اسماء
جديده عن التشكيل في الحكومه السابقه
البنيه التحتيه لوجهه مسار في مكه المكرمه
تقترب من الاكتمال وصلت نسبه الانجاز
93% بنهايه الربع الاول من العام وتمر
الوجهه التنمويه عبر عده مراحل ابرزوا
انجاز البنيه التحتيه لها خلال العام
الجاريه التي تشمل الطرق وانفاق المشاه
والجسور ومحطات المترو ومحطات ومواقف
الحافلات التردديه وتسعى ايضا وجهه مسار
لتوسعه خيارات النقل للزائرين وفق مفهوم
الحركه الشامله التي تمنع تقاطع المركبات
مع المشاه
من مشروع مسار في مكه المكرمه ينضم الينا
مراسل العربيه نواف عزيز نواف مرحبا بك
93%
وحجم الانجاز في وجهه مسار في المرحله
الاولى حدثنا اكثر عن التفاصيل في هذه
المرحله
نعم خالد البناء لا يتوقف في مشروع مسار
مكه غرب العاصمه المقدسه والمسجد الحرام
نسبه الانجاز تجاوزت
93% الاعمال الخاصه بالبناء التحتيه توشك
على الانتهاء من طرق رئيسيه هو ممرات
وايضا مواقف السيارات اتواجد الان فوق
احدى سطوح مباني مواقف السيارات كما نشاهد
الان وهي هذه المباني التي تضم
تستوعب نحو 5000 وستمئه مركبه من خلال
التصميم لهذه الطوابق الخاصه بها الطابق
المبنى الاول
لمواقف السيارات مكون من سبع الطوابق تمتد
على طول مسار مكه بنحو اربع كيلو مترات
تدريجيا تستوعب
الزوار لمسار مكه
قاصدي المسجد الحرام العديد من الاصول
التي اصبحنا نشاهدها الان بعد اكتمال
البناء التحتيه ايضا يتوسط مسار مكه مسجد
كبير يمتد على مساحه
141 الف متر مربع وهو ياتي بالوسط هذا
بالاضافه الى
المشاريع الاخرى ضمن المسار وضمن اعمال
البنى التحتيه هو التي من اهمها حقيقه
الطرق الرئيسيه الطريق
الجنوبي وايضا الطريق الشمالي بالاضافه
الى ممر المشاه الذي نتواجد في بدايته
الان وهو الذي ينقل المشاه من والى المسجد
الحرام ويمرون بالعديد من المشاريع الكبرى
هنا ايضا خالد تتواجد مشاريع تطويريه
جاهزه وقد بدا البناء لها بالفعل من فنادق
وغيرها بالاضافه الى
الاراضي التطويريه وهي اكثر من 200 قطعه
ارض تطويريه ومخصصه للتطوير من مشاريع
فندقيه وسكنيه ايضا بالاضافه الى المشاريع
التجاريه والمرافق الصحيه سيكون هذا
المشروع خالد بعد الانتهاء والذي سيتم
افتتاحه في هذا العام بشكل تدريجي بدءا من
الطرق الرئيسيه
ومعابر المشاه مرورا بافتتاح الاصول
الكبرى للفنادق وغيرها من المهم جدا
الاشاره الى اعداد الفنادق الكبيره التي
ستفتتح في مسار مكه 23 الف غرفه فندقيه
سيتم افتتاحها في مسار مكه تبدا من ثلاث
نجوم وحتى 5 نجوم هذا ليتمكن جميع الزوار
وايضا الحجاج والمعتمرين من الحصول
السكن في هذه الفنادق بمختلف الاسعار وحسب
قدرات كل زائر او معتمر او حاج بالاضافه
الى الشقق الفندقيه التي تزيد عن 13 الف
شقه فندقيه هذا بالاضافه الى المشاريع
السكنيه الاخرى التي يبدا العمل عليها
تزامنا مع انتهاء البناء التحتيه شقق
سكنيه ايضا تتجاوز الثلاثه عشر الف الشقه
سكنيه هو 82 مبنى مخصص للسكن شكرا جزيلا
لك من مشروع مسار مكه المكرمه ينضم مكالمه
معنا مراسل العربيه نواف عزيز
اطلقت اللجنه السعوديه لرعايه السجناء
والمفرج عنهم واوسرهم حمله التبرعات
تستهدف تقديم الدعم والرعايه
لتسعم وعشرين اسره من اسر السجناء الحمله
بدات في المنصه الوطنيه للتبرعات تبرعات
التي تربط بين جهه حكوميه وخيريه مختلفه
لتسهيل عمليه التبرع
يؤدي هذا الممر لبيت بسيط جدا لا يملك
اساسيات الحياه الكريمه
تسكنه اسره تعيش غالب وقتها على تبرعات
الاخرين
بسبب قضاء رب هذه الاسره فتره محكوميته في
السجن والتي تبلغ تسعه اعوام
زي ما انت شايف بيتي ما في اثاث ولا شيء
اكثر شيء محتاج مكيف مكيف
والحمد لله على كل حال يعني
المواد الغذائيه وهذه الحمد لله فاعلين
الخير ما يقصرون
حقه الضمان ان شاء الله انها تتيسر والحمد
لله اهم شيء موجود رز ودقيق الحمد لله
نعمه خير وبركه عند رب العالمين اهم شيء
اني اتمنى
السكن التنموي التعاون معي اعطوني بيت هذا
اهم شيء انضمت ام علي مع 990 اسره لقائمه
الاسر المستحقه للدعم ووضعت حالتهم في
منصه تبرع المنصه الوطنيه للتبرعات التي
تنظم سير العمل الخيري بالشراكه مع الف
وخمسمائه جمعيه خيريه تصل لكافه انواع
المحتاجين ومنهم اسر السجناء
لجنه الوطنيه
للمساجين تراحهم هي لجنه من اللجان
الفاعله في المنصه الوطنيه للتبرعات وتقدم
هذه اللجنه خدمات
للمستفيدين على مستوى كبير اليوم المنصه
الوطنيه للتبرعات مع اللجنه الوطنيه وعدد
كبير من الجمعيات الاهليه
تستطيع ان تحشد العدد الكبير من الاموال
والعدد الكبير من التبرعات وتوجيهها الى
المستفيدين من خلال الجهات الاكثر موثوقيه
حققت منصه تبرع ارقاما كبيره خلال العام
المنصرم حيث تم اغلاق اكثر من 5000
واربعمائه فرصه تبرع من خلال عمليات
التبرع التي بلغت اربعه ملايين عمليه
باجمالي تبرعات وصل الى
927 مليون ريال عبد المحسن الحربي العربيه
الرياض رابع مستمره فيها بعد قليل
رياض اختتم ثلاثه ايام من فعاليه القرقعان
احياء لعاده رمضانيه تراثيه
اهلا بكم تتزين واسقف وحوائط التوسعه
السعوديه الثالثه بالحرم المكي بالثريات
العملاقه ونجاف التي لفتت الاندار
بتصاميمها وزخر فيها الاسلاميه واحجامها
المختلفه وصنعت خصيصا في فيينا باعلى
المواصفات الفنيه
[موسيقى]
بعلو شاهق
وزخارفا اسلاميه ملفته وعبارات ايمانيه
تنطق ثريات المسجد الحرامي المذهب بجمال
استثنائي يمتزج بقدسيه المكان تنير سقف
المسجد باضواء ساطعه تريح النفس والعين
معا
[موسيقى]
هكذا ظهر المسجد الحرام في توسيعته
الثالثه يتزين سقفه بالف وعشرين ثريه
معلقه مختلفه الاشكال والاحجام صنعت خصيصا
للبيت العتيق في فيينا بالنمسا باعلى
المواصفات الفنيه
والتقنيات الحديثه لتكون جزءا لا يتجزا من
الحرم المكي
[موسيقى]
يصل وزن النجفه الرئيسه 25 طنا من المعادن
والزجاج يكف حولها نجف فرعي يصل وزن كل
واحده منها سبعه اطنان وباوزان تتراوح بين
والفينغرام لباقي النجف المتناثر باسقف
التوسعه
[موسيقى]
تتعدد شواهد العنايه بالحرمين في كل
المجالات التي من شانها اثراء تجربه
القاصد والزائر وتوفير كل سبل الراحه
والتيسير عليهم من الحرم المكي سلطان
السلمي العربيه
نبقى ايضا في اجواء رمضان ونذهب الى
المدينه المنوره تحديدا الى مسجد قباء
الذي استقبل اكثر من مليون و80 الف مصلي
منذ بدايه شهر رمضان المبارك يشهد المسجد
اعمال مشروع الملك سلمان لتوسعه مسجد قباء
لتكون اكبر توسعه في تاريخ المسجد وتهدف
الى رفع الطاقه الاستيعابيه الى 66 الف
مسلن بمساحه تصل الى 50 الف متر مربع عشره
اضعاف مساحته الحاليه
للمدينه المنوره من مسجد قباء ينضم الينا
مراسل العربيه سلطان السلام ماذا عن توسعه
مسجد قباء اين وصلنا في اي مرحله لها
اهلا بك خالد واهلا بكافه مشاهدي قناه
العربيه بالفعل بدات هيئه تطوير المدينه
بصرف التعويضات الخاصه بملاك المواقع
والاراضي المجاوره لمسجد قباء كمرحله اولى
لاستكمال عمليات المشروع وبدء تنفيذ
المسارات الثلاثه التي اعلنت عنها مشروع
الملك سلمان لتوسعه مسجد قباء وهي التوسعه
الاكبر على مر التاريخ المسجد التهاب
المسجد يشهد اقبال ملفت وكبير منذ بدايه
شهر رمضان بمعدل 60 الف زائر ومصلي يوميه
اذا تحدثنا فقط عن صلاه التراويح اكثر من
ثلاثين الف مصلي ومصلي يقومون باداء
الصلوات هنا في مسجد قباء ايضا يتحدث على
سبعه ائمه يقومون بامامه المصلين اذ يفتح
المسجد ابوابه طوال اليوم على مدار الساعه
لاستقبال كافه المصلين لاداء الصلوات هنا
في مسجد قباء اعمال التوسعه لا تزال جاريه
على قدم وساق منذ اعلان المشروع العام
الماضي بدات هاي التطوير المدينه بصرف
التعويضات كمرحله اولى اذا تحدثنا انه
هنالك سوف يشهد المسجد مضاعفه في المساحه
بقدر عشره اضعاف مساحته الحاليه وبطاقه
استيعابيه سته وستين الف مصلي طبعا فكره
المشروع او مستهدفات المشروع هي تتماشى من
ضمن برنامج خدمه ضيوف الرحمن وجوده الحياه
كذلك سوف نتحدث عنه سوف يتم رفع المساحه
من المسجد من 5000 وخمسه وثلاثين متر مربع
الى خمسين الف متر مربع نهيك على المسارات
التي سوف تربط المواقع التاريخيه
والاسلاميه بالمسجد عبر مسارات يستطيع من
خلالها الزائر المصلي بعد الانتهاء من
الصلاه المشي عبر هذه المسارات المخصصه
والمهيئه التي سوف تربطه بمساجد تاريخيه
ومواقع اثريه كبيره كمزار ومسار تاريخي
نتحدث على خدمات اخرى مثل خدمات التطوع
وكذلك خدمات الافتاء تقدم هنا في المسجد
ايضا نتحدث على خدمه ذوي الاحتياجات
الخاصه وكبار السن من خلال تخصيص مواقع
لهم ايضا يتحدث على عمليات تطوعيه كبيره
فيما يتعلق بوجبات الافطار يتم فرش بعض
السفر او تم تخصيص قيمه كبيره بجانب
المسجد لتقديم وجبات الافطار للمصلين
والصائمين الخاصيب او الذين قاموا بزياره
مسجد قباء نعم خالد شكرا جزيلا لك اذا
نراسل العربيه سلطان السلمي من مسجد كوبا
في المدينه المنوره
انتهت بالامس فاعليه القرقيعان احدى
فعاليات موسم رمضان الثقافي في الرياض
الفعاليه استمرت ثلاثه ايام في مواقع
متفرقه من الرياض تشاد المتروك
[موسيقى]
بين قصير ورميضه هكذا ردد الاطفال الاغنيه
الرمضانيه احتفالا بفعاليه القرقيعان التي
قدم فيها الاطفال سلال الحلويات للزائرين
[موسيقى]
جايه اوزع قرقيعان وماما اخترت لي لبس
القرقيعان هذا
الملابس اشتريتها بمناسبه رمضان بدا قلنا
القرقيعان وجيت يعني هنا نسوي فعاليات بس
وانا اشتريت عادي
ومن اجل القريعان تزين الاطفال باللباس
الرمضاني التراثي واحتفلوا بالالعاب
والانشطه المخصصه لهم
[موسيقى]
وانبسط والعاب
وانبسطتوا
اعطوني قرقعان وخلصت وانبسطت والله جاي
هنا موسم رمضان عشان
قرقيعان
وعشان نستعرس نلعب ونجمع ايه نلعب صراحه
موسم رمضان احلى موسم مر علي ونذكرني
بالاشياء التراثيه وحسيت ان اليوم
فعاليات الاطفال وغيرها من فعاليات
الاطفال وتوزيعات الحلا وكل شيء حلو لم
يقتصر الاحتفال بالقرقيعان خلال موسم
رمضان على تلك الاغاني او الالعاب فقط بل
حضرت العادات التراثيه كنقش الحنه لتزيين
ايادي الفتيات لنقشات تتناسب مع شهر رمضان
من الرياض شاهد المتروك العربيه
[موسيقى]
مع ظهور التلوث البيئي الناتج عن الثوره
الصناعيه ظهرت اشكاليه حول مواقيت الصلاه
الليليه تفاصيل في تقويم مع خالد الزاحق
[موسيقى]
مواقيت الصلاه خمس اثنين نهاري واثنين
ليلي وواحده فاصله مواقيت صلاه الظهر
والعصر نهاريه والعشاء والفجر ليليه
والمغرب فاصله والمواقيت النهاريه
والفاصله تعتمد على قرص الشمس والليليه
تعتمد على شفق والنهار يولد من رحم الليل
بالانفجار ولهذا سمي فجرا اقم الصلاه
لدلوك الشمس الى غسق الليل وقران الفجر ان
قران الفجر كان مشهوده والفجر فجرين فجر
صادق وهو الذي يعقبه ضوء وفاجر كاذب وهو
الذي يعقبه ظلمه فهو ليس صادقا في ظهوره
لانه لا يعقبه ضوء والعرب القدماء يسمون
الكاذب بذنب السرحان لانه دقيق في اعلاه
ومتسع في اسفله او الذئب فانست بالذ اذ
عوى وصوت انسان فكدت اطير
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وما ظهور التلويث البيئي والضوء الناتج من
الثوره الصناعيه ظهرت اشكاليات حول مواقيت
الصلاه الليليه العشاء والفجر والفجر هو
الاشكال فقدما كان العلماء يقولون ان وقت
صلاه الفجر يحين اذا كان انحطاط قرص الشمس
عن الافق الاقرب 19 او 18 درجه والابحاث
الانيه الدقيقه الحديثه وهي الاصح تقول ان
وقت صلاه الفجر يحين اذا كان انحطاط قرص
الشمس عن الافق الاقرب يا 17 او 16 درجه
والخلاف بينهم اختلاف تنوع ليس اختلاف
تضاد مهما العقول تباينت فيما ترى تبقى
القلوب بودها دوما تفي هب ان رايك غير
رايي يا اخي ما شان ود بيننا
ان يختفي
[موسيقى]
في الاردن تتنوع اشكال الاعمال الخيريه في
رمضان ابرزها تقديم المساعدات للعوائل
المتعففه وللمحتاجين من خلال توفير وجبات
الافطار ومبادرات انسانيه اخرى تستهدف
المحتاجين وتؤمن افطارهم طيله ايام الشهر
الفضيل
[موسيقى]
السبيل والمحتاج والاف الاسر العفيفه
يتجمعون هنا في المكان نفسه والوقت ذاته
من كل عام مشهد مات تقليدا اصيلا في رمضان
فيه موائد الرحمن تستقبل الصائمين وتقدم
لهم وجبات الافطار بحب لا يقابل الا
بالكثير من الحب ودعوه من القلب نقوم على
خدمه حوالي 3500 صائم يوميا بقوم على
خدمتهم حوالي 80 متطوع بالاضافه الى الى
موظفي حاله تفاعليه جميله
والمتطوعين بصراحه في عنا ضغط كبير يعني
من المتطوعين اللي هو صار التطوع موائد
رحمات تقليد يعني من تقاليد رمضان بالنسبه
لهم زي الفانوس سنوات طويله مرت وتكيه ام
علي تعمل على خدمه الصائمين عمل وجد به
المتطوعون اسمى اهدافهم حتى استمر الكثير
منهم بتحضير الطعام وتقديمه في تكيه ام
علي لاكثر من عشر سنوات كل اشي بتقدمه هون
وحتى بتشوف الناس بتكون مبسوطه وانت لما
تقدمي لهم اشي بتكون يعني في
ايجابي منك ومنهم اكيد شعور بالفرح
انه الاقل حظا والناس المحتاجين اكيد شعور
بالعطاء والعطاء ما له حدود اغتنام وشهري
رمضان في عمل الخير له وجه اخر هنا فتحت
عنوان سبيل صويلح يحضر مجموعه من الشباب
وجبات الافطار للعوائل العفيفه كما يقومون
بالبحث عن اي محتاج تعفف عن السؤال نقوم
بتوزيع ما لا يقل عن 100 صدر يوميا ويصل
العدد في بعض الايام الى 130 140 صدر
يوميا بفضل الله تعالى
نستهدف من يعني عملنا بفضل الله تعالى
الاخوه الذين يستحقون عملنا في هذا الشهر
المبارك وما وضع اقتصادي صعب وسوء احوال
الكثير من المواطنين تقدم هذه المبادرات
الرمضانيه جل ما يحتاجه كثيرون في شهر شرع
ابوابه لاعمال الخير سها جميل العربيه
عمان في احداث التصريح يظهر الخلافات بين
واشنطن وباريس جدد ماكرون ان تقلل اوروبا
من اعتمادها على الولايات المتحده
وان تتجنب الانجرار الى مواجهه بين بكين
واشنطن بشاني تايوان ماكرون قال لصاحبه
بوليتيكو ان الخطر الكبير الذي قد تواجهه
اوروبا والوقوع في ازمات ليست ازماتها
مؤكدا انه ليس مع من مصلحه اوروبا تسريع
ازمه تايوان وبناء موقفها بالتبعيه
للولايات المتحده او بتلميحات من الصين
معتبرا انه في حال اشتدت التوترات بين
هاتين القوتين فلن يكون لاوروبا الوقت ولا
الموارد لتمويل استقلالها الاستراتيجي
اضاف ماكرون ان على اوروبا تقرير اعتمادها
على الدولار الامريكي خارج الحدود
الاقليميه
تامر رئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
الديمقراطيين عبر منصه تروت بتدمير امريكا
ووصفهم بالحزب اليساري الضعيف الذي يسعى
لتدمير المجتمع الامريكي وتوعد ترامب
الحزمه الحزب الديمقراطي بالعوده الى
الرئاسه مشيرا الى ضروره الغاء التصويت
الالكتروني لانهاء الاحتيال على اصوات
الناخبين والاعتماد على التصويت الورقي
فقط على حديث تعبيره
العناوين
وكاله رويترز تؤكدان سعوديين وعمانيه
بتشكيل الحكومات الكويتيه الجديده 14
وزيرا برئاسه الشيخ احمد النواف
رابع تقف على واقع وجهه مسار مكه انجاز
93% من البنيه التحتيه للمشروع حتى الان
تختتم ثلاثه ايام من فعاليه القرقعان
احياء لعاده رمضانيه تراثيه
نهايه الرابعه شكرا متابعه الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات